what a treat I get both of you are so
excited
[Music]
where do we find your character where do
we find it um so Diana has been around
you know in the first movie we got to to
establish Wonder Woman and to tell the
journey of Diana Prince becoming Wonder
Woman right and in this story we meet
her in 1984 she's been around she's been
helping mankind you know doing what she
feels she needs to do her calling pretty
lonely because she lost some of her
teammates along there over the years and
then something crazy is about to happen
to her sorry going now after you saw
this film I cut maybe like one of the
first cuts of this film I hear you cry
is it Harry yes and I'm not an easy
crier
yeah just to you know save my baby like
without magnets I'm not the type of
women who watch commercials and cry but
you did on the first one but you didn't
know I had such a strong reaction to
this movie and he caught me off guard
why um I think it's it's I can't tell
you what happened in the movie that made
me cry I can just say it was the very
beginning but I've never seen that all
of a sudden I wasn't the girl Wonder
Woman the actress the producer poor and
set and were they are when everything
was shot I was little girl from a suburb
in Israel watching all by myself in the
cinema which is for itself a surreal
experience watching this thing and I've
seen this amazing woman girl doing this
amazing things and I did not expect that
and all of sudden I didn't even notice
you know I forgot it was so it was very
effective and that's that's the moments
where you're like this is why it's so
freaking important this is why it's not
like any other movie it's we're doing
something that's that we hope is gonna
have an impact but it hasn't
it's very impactful on us already so
touchwood it's a good sign and I hope
your you and the audience will have the
similar reaction I mean if you Haley
aspire to do something special and
unique and meaningful well I mean and it
must have maybe it brought emotions upon
you because here you are suiting up for
the second time in this iconic role and
you're a mom of two daughters yeah
that's you for sure I'm sure but I gotta
tell you it's not just for the girls it
is for the girls but you can't we can't
reach the place where we're gonna stop
talking about female men you know women
empowerment feminism and all that before
we work on both you know female and male
like we can't just empower women Joan
Lee by focusing on women we also need to
educate the boys and the men so you know
a young boy that goes to see the in the
cinema this amazing woman does those
amazing things that he can't believe a
woman could do that right you know what
I mean so it it goes both ways
and you guys have done such a great job
hearing up it's two fearless women I
mean just taking on the big screen was
the most difficult thing for you in
bringing this comeback the sequel to the
big screen you know I think every time I
make a movie I'm trying to make a
masterpiece like that's what you'll
never get there you'll never feel that
you did but that's always what you're
trying to do so as wonderful as the
success of the first movie was this is
its own movie and I love this character
and I love this person that I'm working
with so this movie you know that movie
was done but even while I was making
that movie I started to see what I felt
like the second movie could be its own
movie okay so on standalone it's totally
it is a it's it has to do it's the same
characters and there's and we don't
break time continuity it's not a reboot
it's a sequel in that way but it's not a
sequel to a story it's its own story and
so it was something
really started to to come upon me while
we were shooting the first movie and we
started to work on it then so you know I
I I am aiming for this movie to be
better in every way and I feel like we
aspired to make something that we felt
was grand and fantastic and something
you'd want to go see in the theatres and
you know we did something that I think
is super exciting which is you know
someone was just asking me about
technology and saying do you feel the
need to stay ahead of the curve I said
no I don't I just feel I need to make a
great movie however when I've observed
what was happening in technology I said
how about we do the opposite instead of
using technology to do more things on
green-screen and in CGI let's use
technology to get wires to do things to
make people do it for real so we do so
much of this movie as practical action
it was so incredible to watch because we
went to real locations and we shot real
people doing real incredible sequences
on wires and and a lot of the wire rigs
we did no one's ever done before because
no one's ever the wires have gotten so
sophisticated but it's gone out of vogue
of shooting that way have like special
videos for that cuz it was all so big
weeks and weeks of rig yeah really hard
for her really hard for the actors but
it was like I I got a recovery I feel so
I feel so lucky we got to make this
massive grand film and we are flashing
back to 1984 so perhaps that's why we're
taking a little throwback to some of
these means of filming so yeah can't
wait to see the big hair
[Laughter]
[Music]